quatre ans après le plan charest le
gouvernement couillard redonne vie au
plan nord ce sera le plan de la relance
économique
le rempart de l'austérité les chiffres
sont éléphantesque ils font rêver sur 20
ans le gouvernement prévoit des
investissements de l'ordre de 50
milliards de dollars il s'engagera de
son côté à y investir près de 2
milliards 800 millions de dollars pour
construire des routes pour former de la
main d'oeuvre ou encore pour aider
l'entreprise à s'installer dans les
communautés autochtones les retombées
fiscales sont évalués à plus de 2
milliards de dollars le premier ministre
accompagné d'une dizaine de ministres
donnera le coup d'envoi au premier plan
quinquennal
actuellement 17 projets miniers sont
dans les cartons on en connaît déjà
quelques-uns comme la meynard nos ou le
diamantaire stornoway au cours des cinq
prochaines années québec pense que lee
minière investiront au nord du 49e
parallèle quelque 22 milliards de
dollars et créeront près de 10000
emplois c'est la société du plan nord
qui ouvre ses portes aujourd'hui qui
pilotera le projet le plan charest dit
sa présidente a eu une courte vie à
peine un an après son annonce des
élections étaient déclenchées
la base est la même à écouter la volonté
la base est la même mais elles font ce
que l'acs social était la faiblesse du
plan charest québec proposera un pont
entre l'entreprise et les communautés
des projets pilotes parrainé par la
ministre déléguée à la santé publique
seront mis en place avec deux ou trois
entreprises on va consulter plus le
milieu en bref s'approprier plus le
milieu et
il ya plus de gens du milieu qui vont
être impliqués peut-être mais le marché
des métaux est à la baisse mais québec
veut envoyer le signal qu'ils se
préparent au retour des beaux jours ça
nous donne l'opportunité de mettre en
place des bonnes structures appelées
avant dé bonne planification il reste
que le projet couillard est beaucoup
plus conservateur que ce que laissait
miroiter le plan charest il prévoit que
les investissements seront 30 milliards
de dollars moins élevé le gouvernement
diminue aussi sa contribution sur cinq
ans des deux tiers
martin donc plan nord prise 2 est ce que
cette nouvelle mouture a plus de chances
de réussir quel signal le gouvernement
veut-il envoyer les mesures d'austérité
céline commence à peser le gouvernement
a besoin d'une vision d'un projet
porteur d'espoir et le plan nord est un
projet clé en main qui a été élaboré par
le gouvernement charest en plein boom
minier et qui a pris le chemin de la
tablette quand le parti québécois a été
élu alors le gouvernement couillard l'a
remis à jour et le signal qu'il envoie
ses 4 3 ans de la fin son mandat il est
sérieux et que même s'il a peu de moyens
le travail avec les communautés et les
municipalités avancera il n'empêche que
tout ça dépend bien sûr du prix des
métaux qui est à la baisse soyons
honnêtes c'est l'insee les prix des
métaux remontent
on se bousculera pour investir dans le
nord mais le pari que fait le
gouvernement c'est que bien préparé plus
de québécois pourront en profiter très
bien merci beaucoup martin au revoir je
me tourne maintenant vers gérald morale
qui va nous parler justement du marché
des métaux toujours un peu en déprime
absolument lorsque jean charest a
présenté son plan nord en 2011 les prix
étaient hauts plafonds on était à 10 e
mais lisait les minières voulait
investir à ce moment là aujourd'hui on
est dans des circonstances complètement
différente depuis 2011 les prix sont en
baisse depuis les sommets de 2011 quand
on regarde les principaux métaux du
québec l'argent le prix de l'argent a
baissé de 61% sur le marché
international le cuivre de 42% le faire
de 67% du nickel de 49 lors de 31 et les
22 15 pour ça essentiellement parce que
la demande de la chine n'a pas cessé de
décroître ou de ralentir au cours des
dernières années je vois six chiffres
est ce que le québec va s'endetter avec
les milliards qui sont investis dans le
plan nord vont s'ajouter aux autres
milliards 1 milliards qui sont investis
dans les infrastructures se fait
essentiellement par endettement la dette
brute du québec de 2014 à 2020 va passer
de 197 à 220 milliards de dollars mais
quand on regarde la dette c'est par
rapport à l'ensemble de l'économie il
faut regarder ça on prévoit selon
dernier budget l'état au que la dette
brute représente 54% aujourd'hui de
notre économie ça va tomber à 49% mais
ça pour ça ça prend de la croissance
économique faut que le plan nord
notamment génère de la croissance
économique au québec